hey what's up my name is samuel leeds
and right now i wanted to talk about
what's going on in the property market
house prices rents what's happening i
want to look back over the last year or
so some of the predictions that i've
been saying
and also to talk a bit about what house
prices are likely to do
in the coming weeks and months so if you
enjoy my youtube channel please do me a
massive favor
let me know let me know by smashing the
like button
also don't forget to subscribe and turn
the notification bell
on that would be amazing so okay right
move
right move i've been writing a lot
recently um about
house prices they've said that house
prices
in the uk have hit record highs
for the third month in a row house
prices are going
crazy i mean how long do i need to keep
telling people
to buy properties before people are
actually gonna start doing it
um most people are waiting to see what's
gonna happen they're waiting to see
but listen lockdown is almost over now i
remember at the start of lockdown
and i was saying to everybody hey the
rich are going to get richer
the poor are going to get poorer the
divide is going to happen don't be
saving money in the bank start buying
real estate
rent it out sit on it it will hold its
value
and at the time 18 months ago a year ago
everyone was saying well let's just see
what's going to happen
and then i'll go back a little bit
before that a year before that
and everyone was saying well let's see
what's going to happen with brexit once
brexit's over
once lockdown's over guess what in
another year there'll probably be
something else that happens
there'll be some new rule there'll be
some change and people say oh well let's
just
let's just wait and see meanwhile i made
a prediction
that there was going to be more and more
millionaires being created
and lo and behold there's just been an
article released by
let me let me show you this because it's
just like come on look this is by the
independent
what does it say it says that millions
more become millionaires during pandemic
during pandemic as property prices saw
that is millions of people
are becoming millionaires last year
there was 5 million people
last year that became a millionaire for
the first time
now the reason that's happening and
that's gonna keep happening by the way
more and more people are gonna become
millionaires
there's two reasons one is because
there's more opportunity
to make money than there ever has been
certainly in my lifetime
but secondly that's because being a
millionaire
is becoming less and less impressive as
they're printing more and more money
in the uk alone they've printed hundreds
of billions
that money that's printed gets pumped
into the
just into the world right and and
people get richer because of it however
a millionaire
isn't as impressive now than it was
before because money is shrinking
so people that are saving up money and
putting in the bank
and working hard for it are just
financially not very smart
while they're printing money so my
advice is to start buying properties now
here's the thing
what's going to happen to properties
they're going to keep going up i mean
the boom has been going on now we've
been in the boom for like a year they're
going to keep going up
of course as i always say it depends on
the area there's some areas where it's
going to keep going up
there's some areas where it's going to
start dipping but here's the really
really
really exciting thing the really
exciting thing
is that rents here's another interesting
stat for you
i'm when i first started investing in
property about 2008 2009
during the crash during the recession
everyone's saying to me be careful be
careful it's risky it's a bad time i
mean jeez everyone says that always
i can guarantee in 50 years time when
i'm an old man in my rocking chair
people are going to say well just wait
and see what happens next year but
people were worried then not only if
properties doubled in value then but
hear this
rents are up by 68
since the last crash okay this is a
property reporter
rental incomes up by 68 since the last
property market crash
check this out so what does that mean
well if rents are going
up which they are as well as house
prices that means that when you buy a
house
not only are you going to wait for the
property to go up and the property is
going to hold its value
but also your monthly income is going to
be going up
so with all these new people becoming
millionaires
in the property space in the uk and
overseas
i decided to put a training program on
called the property
millionaire intensive now look i told
you about this program last week
uh in london and it's now sold
out all right finished however the good
news is i'm running the program across
the country so i have a few more dates
available birmingham's got a few tickets
left it's a free training program
uh there's a one-pound booking fee but
just to check your real person but it's
free
but spaces are limited so if you think
if you're tired
of waiting to see what happens and if
you're ready to just
jump on right now and start making some
money and
i'll show you how i became a millionaire
i'll show you how many of my students
have become a millionaire
and i'll show you how you can start
making some serious money in property
two
and i'd like to invite you for free to
come down and join me
this month it's happening so i'll leave
a link in the description where you can
join me at the property
millionaire intensive jump on this boom
jump on this trend
because all is going to happen is over
the next few years
the people that are comfortable or poor
are going to get more and more
more and more uncomfortable and the poor
are going to get poorer and it's a shame
i don't like it
the rich are going to get richer it's
not fair i agree
but all i can do is show you how i'm
getting richer and richer through
property development through
biorefurbish refinance through
holding onto property and waiting show
you what i'm doing show what my students
are doing and hopefully you'll join the
side of the rich so i'll leave a link in
the description
stop making excuses book on book on now
and i'll see you real soon peace out god
[Music]
bless
[Music]
you